[Música]
desde el éxito de la Macarena ningún
tema en español se había convertido en
un hit internacional hasta que Luis
Fonsi y Daddy Yankee conquistaron las
pistas de baile con todo el mundo con su
famosa canción despacito desde entonces
los cantantes latinos como Bad Bunny
Shakira o Karol G y ahora peso pluma
solo para mencionar algunos están en los
rankings mundiales sobre todo gracias al
reggaetón para analizar este fenómeno
nos acompaña en estudio Felipe Lugo
gerente de marketing de la disquera
independiente alta fonte para
latinoamérica y Centroamérica y también
cofundador del sello rolo Records Felipe
Gracias por estar aquí con nosotros
gracias a ustedes Comencemos con la
pregunta básica y es cuál es el secreto
del éxito o del reggaetón más que el
reggaeton Yo creo que es de la música
latina digamos que las personas que no
son de esta industria y de esta tierra
no entienden bien porque se están dando
los números que se están Y es de locos
que lo que en cierto momento fue un hito
como lo de despacito los lanzamientos de
hoy lo hagan parecer como algo pequeño y
niño no resulta que nosotros venimos de
una tierra donde es normal el mestizaje
el atrevimiento a mezclar cosas
pasarnos la regla y el género por encima
y eso nos ha generado la posibilidad de
hacer fenómenos como lo que representa
el corrido tumbado que es la mezcla del
regional mexicano con la estética del
trap un poco también el éxito de lo que
ha tenido el reggaetón es el desarrollo
de una imagen de lo latino no que mezcla
El hip hop que tiene una herencia de la
salsa que tiene una herencia de Lo negro
que también tiene elementos indígenas
Ese es nuestro mayor hito Pues que
nosotros somos parte de un pueblo que ha
mezclado elementos que van desde el
europeo y occidental atravesando lo
negro y lo africano con las músicas
indígenas Y esa es una fórmula que es
imposible replicar en cualquier otro
lado del mundo porque no existe la
posibilidad de hacer ese mestizaje que
no solo sucede en la música sino también
en la cocina y por eso peruana es una de
las más increíbles del mundo y por eso
la música latina es imposible imitar
porque aunque sepas hablar español no
tienes los elementos del sabor y del
mestizaje para poderla llevar a realizar
de la manera como se realiza hoy usted
hablaba del mestizaje concretamente con
los corridos o lo que usted llamó ha
ocurrido tumbado que es la combinación
entre este folclor mexicano con el trap
y que sin duda ha hecho de peso pluma el
artista del momento y para eso un dato
en este momento en el top de las 50
canciones más escuchadas en Spotify en
todo el mundo de las diez cinco son en
español y de Esas cinco cuatro son de
este corrido tumbado A qué se debe el
éxito de este género resulta que México
Había sido un mercado que históricamente
no había internacionalizado su música
Ellos tenían una industria a excepción
de países como Colombia que digamos
tiene una tradición mariachi los
mexicanos siempre habían hecho música
para mover en ese mismo círculo con la
expansión y la migración mexicana a
Estados Unidos que siempre ha existido
se desarrolló esta figura de cómo
hacemos que nuestra cultura porque ellos
no son reggaetoneros A diferencia de los
caribeños Ellos tienen otra música y
otro sonido cómo hacemos que nuestra
música pueda entrar en esta ecuación de
la música latina entonces a través de
una figura muy importante que realmente
se llama Natanael Cano no pesó pluma él
llevó a cabo ese mestizaje que el
reggaetón hizo con la música caribeña
pero con la música de su país que era el
regional mexicano el corrido que hizo lo
fusionó con elementos trap
principalmente a través de la estética
porque es muy importante para nuestros
géneros lo visual el marketing la música
hoy entra más por los ojos que nunca y a
raíz de eso logró un fenómeno
internacional que terminó llegando hasta
bizarra porque bizarra digamos que es
este radar de Novedades ya para entrar a
lo mainstream él es este gran referente
de producción latina que al público
general es el que le dice Hey por aquí
va el cuento hoy por acá va entonces
realmente es una mezcla de varios
elementos pero sobre todo que cuando
habían visto ustedes la colaboración de
un mexicano y un argentino que diera sus
números no Esa es la Ese es el poder de
lo latino que nosotros miramos por
encima de la bandera total una
combinación que no se había visto antes
usted habla de cuál fue ese punto de
inflexión del corrido y que fue mucho
antes de peso pluma Pero cuéntenos en
qué momento fue ese auge meteórico de
los artistas en español que ya no
necesitan cantar en inglés para sus
conciertos en todo el mundo tenemos al
mundo hablando español por el internet
realmente el internet fue la
infraestructura digital que nos permitió
a nosotros no solo desde el arte porque
el arte es uno de los factores sino como
creadores de contenido volvernos
mundiales porque en el internet no hay
que competir con esa infraestructura
económica y de Mercado que existían los
90s y a principios de los 2000 donde
solo grandes corporaciones en lugares
anglos determinaban que era valioso y
que el internet digamos que hay una
democracia del público donde la gente a
raíz de lo que consume termina
determinando las fronteras del mercado
yo por ejemplo creo que la cultura está
por encima del mercado solo que en la
infraestructura que había anteriormente
era difícil que eso se notara tanto pero
por ejemplo si la gente quiere escuchar
corrido tumbado si lo prohíban en las
escuelas lo van a escuchar Sí o sea creo
que nuestra mayor herramienta para Haber
puesto al mundo hablar español fue el
internet pero sobre todo nuestra
creatividad para entender como con lo
menos posible volvernos mundiales creo
que ese es el Ingenio latino y con lo
que usted está explicando me da a
entender que también es la razón el
internet por la que los ritmos africanos
en este momento también están en auge
por ejemplo con los nigerianos como
bernaboy o whisky Usted cree que estos
afrobits puedan reemplazar al reggaetón
Yo creo que la afrovich siempre ha
estado en la esencia de la música latina
También nosotros tenemos una herencia
africana muy importante
que se ha traducido desde nuestros
sonidos más primigenios y más
recientemente lo vemos en la salsa pero
en casi todos los géneros desde que
llegaron acá los europeos que trajeron
africanos Nosotros hemos hecho música
atrevida entonces también hay mucho
Afrodita en Colombia hay mucho afrodito
hecho en las islas caribeñas siempre si
uno se puede escandalizar de lo similar
que puede sonar algo en Haití en senegal
o sea realmente no se trata del punto
geográfico sino de la idea Yo creo que
la música negra y la música latina no
corresponde a un espacio Terrenal sino a
una idea y esa idea es lo que ha hecho
tan poderoso que esos géneros empaten
con nosotros qué es lo que la gente
coloquialmente llama el sabor no como
esto tiene mucho sabor conecto con esto
realmente es el uso de elementos
rítmicos que la música viene de África
siempre va a volver a África Entonces
por esa razón Creo que es importante
abrir la perspectiva y permitirse
conectar uno con el origen detrás de los
elementos complementando eso creo que es
importante también hablar de la figura
de los creadores de contenido No
necesariamente músicos sino melómanos
ahorita es muy importante para
complementar lo que pasa del lado del
artista la historia detrás de la canción
nosotros desde altafonte hicimos
recientemente una campaña con Lucho ario
un creador de contenido en tiktok en el
que el hablo de Wendy sulca la cantante
peruana de folclor andino y el video
contó la historia de ella y como su
última canción habla de ese orgullo
andino entre las montañas y superar el
bullying y el crecer de una persona que
desde niña sufrió mucho bullying en
internet Entonces la historia detrás de
la canción lo que genera es un
conocimiento masivo de la gente para
bajar al artista de donde estaban los 90
o en los 2000 que era ese artista
inalcanzable a humanizarlo nosotros
estamos mucho más cerca del artista hoy
que hace 20 años y mucho más cerca
entonces del sabor con internet Felipe
Gracias por estar aquí con nosotros y
ustedes Gracias por preferir Franz 24
sigan con nosotros Porque volvemos con
más en minutos
[Música]